[Music]
so I have a missed call from court and I
call her back and she was at me and
Kendall we're talking about you and she
goes you're really scared about how your
life is gonna turn out
the feud continues between the
Kardashian sisters
she thinks I'm scared and that's why I'm
acting out cuz I don't want to let my
old life go what an a sneak peek of
Sunday's Keeping Up with the Kardashians
Chloe meets up with Kim to talk about
their latest frustrations with Kourtney
what are we gonna do cuz it's hard for
me to like even be around her at this
point the girls decide to FaceTime
little sis Kendall Jenner to get her
thoughts the fact that you even hang out
with Kourtney you're such a freak I'm
just kidding I'm as my best friend right
now I question your morals then Kendall
drops this bombshell about Kourt what
what and Kim's response is priceless but
do you think you take a try for help
like like a cry for attention
is she the new Rob in the season
premiere the sisters had a blowout fight
about the family's holiday card and
courts latest move to skip Christmas
seems to be the icing on the family
drama cake drives me so crazy I just
don't even know what to do
keeping it all in the fam Kim and her
hubby Kanye are currently living their
best lives on vacation this amid news
they may be looking to have another kid
I love that a source close to the couple
tells et they quote have always wanted a
big family and if a fourth child is in
their cards they will be ecstatic with
the new addition
[Music]